TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
Android Studio 3.2 is now
available for download.
Head on over to the post
linked in the description
below for the latest details
on key features such as Android
app bundle, the energy profiler,
and the new Android Emulator
snapshots.
We recently released updates
to ARCore, our platform
for building augmented
reality experiences.
We also updated Scene
Form, the 3D rendering
library for building AR
applications on Android.
Included are
algorithm improvements
that will let your apps
consume less memory and CPU
usage during longer
sessions, as well as
new functionality that gives you
more flexibility over content
management.
Code and example
screenshots are on the post.
The Cloud Native
Community Foundation
announced Kubernetes
1.12 last week.
This post highlights
some of the development
that Google Cloud is driving
in the Kubernetes open source
project, including faster
scaling, topology aware storage
provisioning, and
advanced auditing.
Recently, we
announced Cloud Tasks.
It's a task queue service
for App Engine Flex
and second generation
runtimes that
provides all the benefits
of a distributed task
queue, including
task offloading,
loose coupling between
services, and enhanced system
reliability.
For more details and
links to get started,
head on over to the post.
The Google Fonts catalog now
includes Japanese web fonts.
For some details on the
optimization involved,
take a look at the post.
It's been nearly a decade
since we launched the Chrome
extensions system, and nearly
half of Chrome desktop users
actively use
extensions to customize
Chrome and their
experience on the web.
It's crucial that these
users be able to trust
that the extensions they install
are safe, privacy preserving,
and performant.
So we recently announced
some upcoming changes,
including user controls for
host permissions, changes
to the extensions
review process,
and new code readability
requirements.
Click through to the post
linked in the description
below for all the details.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Hello, I'm Timothy Jordan
for "The Developer Show."
SPEAKER 1: Once more--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: [LAUGHING]
Yeah, OK.
Now?